bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs à
vous idées de sorties dans ce magazine
nous vous présenterons la nouvelle
médiathèque de montigny le bretonneux le
petit canal la structure en place
provisoirement provisoirement la
médiathèque le kanak qui est en
rénovation il sera aussi question le
trompe l'oeil dans cette émission les
étudiants de l'école d'art mural de
versailles ont exposé leurs travaux dans
l'enceinte du château et le week-end
sera aussi sportive sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines alexandre
vialle vous propose ce samedi et ce
dimanche un circuit training dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nous le recevrons sur ce
plateau en fin d'émission
après deux semaines de fermeture la
médiathèque du canada investit ses
nouveaux locaux ce mercredi la structure
accueille désormais le public au
deuxième étage du centre commercial sqy
ouest la médiathèque passe de 2700
mètres carrés à 700 mètres carrés et
s'appelle désormais le petit canal les
détails avec mélanie poké et mathilde eu
qu'à berne
appelez-la dorénavant la médiathèque du
petit canal depuis ce matin 10 heures la
structure a ouvert ses portes dans ses
nouveaux locaux à skywest après deux
semaines de déménagement j'ai une fille
qui est très grosse liseuses et qui
emprunte s'est régulièrement des
bouquins donc on est assez impatient
c'est pas mal de bons joueurs mais pas
du provisoire c'est profitable et c'est
bon c'est pas mal avant 10 heures il y
avait déjà pas mal de public bach
attendait qu'on ouvre
les portes l'ensemble du personnel était
là pour pour les accueillir donc pour
nous c'est un moment très attendu parce
qu'on a passé de nombreuses semaines à
préparer la réouverture de la
réouverture l'ouverture de cette
médiathèque donc voilà on est très
contents que
d'avoir de nouveau ouvert ses portes et
piles mettre à disposition tout cet
espace un espace qui est plus réduit que
les locaux situés sous le théâtre
national
auparavant de 2700 mètres carrés il est
dorénavant de 700 m² une réduction qui
demande une nouvelle organisation
on en a profité en fait pour faire des
regroupements de collection donc
notamment au niveau des documentaires on
a mélangé les collections pour adultes
et pour enfants et on va souhaiter là
aussi quand même faire vivre cet espace
pas seulement par les collections qu'on
propose mais aussi par des rendez vous
donc on va continuer à organiser
certains de nos rendez vous ici
et puis on a aussi profité de ce
déménagement pour créer des partenariats
avec des structures culturelles qui
appartenait l'agglomération la
médiathèque du petit canal restera
skywest durant un an le temps que les
travaux de rénovation de l'ancien site
soit terminé l'accueil et les horaires
eux n'ont pas changé
pour nous parler de l'ouverture de la
médiathèque le petit canal nous recevons
sur ce plateau cécile affaire at-on
alors vous êtes responsable du service
aménagement et spectacle à la
médiathèque le petit canal alors
justement l'a vu dans ce reportage la
médiathèque du canal donc il est passé
donc de 2700 mètres carrés à 700 mètres
carrés et elle s'appelle désormais donc
le petit canal et non le canal voilà
mais du coup du coup cette structure est
ce qu'il ya exactement les mêmes
documents qu'on avait dans l'ancienne
structure alors forcément on en a
beaucoup moins puisqu'on a beaucoup
moins de place mais par contre on a
souhaité quand même pouvoir continuer à
proposer tous les types de documents et
tous les supports donc en fait on a fait
une sélection un petit peu pour chaque
collection pourquoi justement tous les
usagers puissent quand même continuer à
trouver des choses qui leur
correspondent sachant que chacun a
finalement c'est ses centres d'intérêt
et donc n'attend pas la même chose
finalement de la médiathèque et à ce que
du coup ça fonctionne exactement comme
avant il n'y a pas de changement elle en
termes de service et de propositions non
c'est exactement le même système pour
les inscriptions pour les emprunts pour
les réservations tout ça ça n'a pas
changé en fait c'était vraiment une
volonté les horaires non plus n'ont pas
changé c'était vraiment une volonté de
rester sur les mêmes services proposés
avec bien sûr un espace qui lui est
adaptée il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour la réouverture mercredi dernier est
ce que c'était vraiment attendu 7 700
verture ce donc ça fermé pendant deux
semaines est ce que cette
ouverture était vraiment entendu parler
habituel je pense qu'on peut dire ça où
il s'était vraiment attendu alors
effectivement il y avait déjà des gens
derrière les portes avant 10 heures
mercredi et puis effectivement quand on
a regardé vraiment les statistiques le
lendemain s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
eu autant de monde au petit canal car
mercredi ordinaire à la médiathèque du
canal donc ce qui veut dire que je pense
vraiment que les gens attendaient notre
et ouverture et à ce qu'au niveau des
choix de documents est ce qu'il n'ya il
y en a autant que lors de vin que dans
la précédente médiathèque alors non
effectivement comme on est passé de 2700
mètres carrés 700 m² on en a beaucoup
moins donc effectivement la sélection
est beaucoup plus du coup je sais c'est
sympa c'est comment pour cette sélection
alors en fait on avait on avait mis en
place ba déjà des quotas de sélection
par types de documents par support et
puis à l'intérieur en fait on avait on
avait quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
fin par genres musicaux par exemple ou
par genre pour les films ou à
l'intérieur des romans on a pris plus de
francophones ou plus anglo-saxon alors
on avait on avait en fait des films des
critères de cet ordre là pour nous aider
à choisir justement parce que ben voilà
il fallait bien faire un choix donc ça
n'a pas forcément été simple pour pour
toutes les collections pour les
collègues au 6 mai mais voilà on s'est
efforcé de faire quelque chose qui
puisse correspondre à bas tous types
d'usagés en fait donc dans la précédente
médiathèque y avait également des
animations est ce qu'ils seront
conservés dans cette médiathèque du
petit canal alors on a fait en sorte de
pour en conserver le plus possible bien
sûr comme l'espace n'est pas le même il
ya des choses qui ne sont plus plus
possible on par exemple les ateliers
jeux vidéo qui était mise en place par
contre on a souhaité conserver en fait
tous les toutes les animations qui
pouvaient être adaptées aux lieux alors
des fois c'est la fréquence si elle
changé mais en tout cas on continue à
faire ses animations là là aussi c'était
vraiment une volonté pour faire vivre
faire vivre le lieu en fait et puis
aussi ne pas perdre l'habitude en fait
de ces animations là et puis continuer à
fidéliser notre public coin ou un
nouveau public d'ailleurs mais quels
seront les prochains rendez-vous gestion
alors justement on a commencé dès
mercredi en fait on a on a repris nos
rendez vous régulier des premiers jours
relation voilà dès le premier jour une
animation et là la prochaine et demain
matin donc c'est un rendez-vous qui
s'appelle mon petit doigt m'a dit donc
qui à destination d moins de trois ans
avec leurs parents et donc là vraiment
on est sur des histoires des petites
comptines des jeux de doigts qui sont
fait donc avec les enfants et les
parents et animé par des bibliothécaires
alors le thème de demain c'est sur les
insectes ou les insectes et les petites
bêtes voilà donc c'est ouvert à tout le
monde alors là oui l'idée c'est vraiment
de venir en famille par contre c'est
réservé aux plus petits là on est
vraiment sur un rendez-vous qui est pour
les plus petits il est donc les moins de
3 ans donc à partir des fat des bébés
jusqu'à jusqu'à deux ans et demi trois
donc ça se passe comment les parents
visuels viennent avec leurs enfants les
laisse sur place restait alors non
justement là il reste avec eux comme ce
sont des tout petits et puis l'idée
c'est aussi qu'ils fassent finalement
les je dois les comptines les histoires
avec les enfants là on est vraiment sur
un temps des changes en fait parents
enfants et bibliothécaires en fait qui
sert uniquement de médiateurs de toutes
ces histoires de toutes ces comptines et
ce type de rendez vous il y en aura
fréquemment l'avenir alors oui on essaye
d'en faire entre 1 et 2 par mois donc
toujours le samedi matin à 10h30 et ça
dure à peu près une demi heure pour que
justement les petits puissent rester
attentif à peu près ce temps là en fait
est ce qu'il y aura d'autres événements
peut-être qu'ils vont être créés dans
l'allier dans la médiathèque le petit
canal alors est ce que justement le
problème est justement des 2700 mètres
carrés qui passe à 700 mètres carrés ça
vous bloque au niveau des alors pas
forcément il ya des choses que forcément
on adapte donc même les rendez vous
réguliers 1 comme les heures du conte
tous les ateliers on va être obligé de
les adapter les adapter un petit peu
après c'est aussi l'occasion pour nous
peut-être de réorienter un petit peu ce
qu'on fait de repenser et peut-être
certaines choses ou de viser des publics
peut-être un petit peu différent des
habituels ont donc par exemple les
ateliers jusqu'à présent était plutôt
orientée pour les enfants là on souhaite
que ça soit quelque chose qui soit aussi
à destination des ados et des adultes
d'autant plus que ça sera finalement
peut-être plus visible aussi de tout le
public que ça l'était avant puisqu'on
était sur plusieurs étages
et puis il ya également des initiatives
qui sont un petit peu différente avec
des partenaires donc par exemple on
faisait jusqu'à présent des ateliers
numériques et là le prochain
qui aura lieu samedi aura lieu à la
commanderie des templiers c'est en fait
on a mis en place une un partenariat et
là on aura à la fois la partie
bibliothécaire avec un atelier numérique
et et l'intervention d'une artiste en
résidence là-bas en fait donc là on a
vraiment essayé de couple et c'était
l'occasion aussi de couple et peut-être
différentes approches voilà merci
beaucoup c'est si le faire à temps
j'étais ravie de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau on passe tout de suite au rendez
vous musicaux elle du week-end
durant le mois d'avril la musique du
monde est à l'honneur à la verrière des
ateliers parents et enfants sont
programmés à l'espace culturel aimé
césaire pour découvrir en famille les
traditions musicales à de cinq régions
du monde le reportage est signée yolaine
torres et aux idéaux dit mme wang
ils viennent du monde entier d'afrique
d'asie ou encore d'amérique ces
instruments d'une qualité rare se sont
installés à la verrière au sein de
l'espace culturel aimé césaire
l'objectif est de mettre en lumière les
liens qui existent entre ces différentes
traditions musicales certains de ces
instruments peuvent avoir des liens très
forts certains de ces instruments ou une
histoire commune et ont traversé les
siècles frontières ont traversé les
océans pour migrer avec à
avec les peuples d'impayés en parallèle
des ateliers parents enfants sont
organisés de quoi découvrir en famille
les traditions musicales de simples et
régions du monde ce jour là les
percussions mandingues sont à l'honneur
avec une initiation au djembé
nous avons tous à un imaginaire en fait
des musiques du monde même si certains
instruments nous semble assez exotique
avec des formes assez incroyable on a
tous en tête des sons des musiques des
mélodies qui nous font penser
immédiatement à l'asie à la chine ou au
brésil
travailler qui
d'autre
c'est à ce moment que l'on n'avait
jamais
jamais jouer donc on commence à sortir
des sons alors qu'on n'a jamais sortir
une sorte de n'importe quel instrument
la prochaine session prévue le lundi 13
avril de 18 heures à 19 heures un
spectacle de restitution est également
prévue dans le mois
nous poursuivrons ce magazine avec une
forme d'art le trompe l'oeil à
l'occasion des journées européennes de
l'artisanat d'art coup de projecteur sur
cette technique les étudiants de l'école
d'art mural de versailles ont exposé
leurs travaux dans l'enceinte du château
un reportage signé catherine azules à
tous
ces motifs fleuris ce sont des
grotesques l'art du trompe-l'oeil
proposé aux regards des visiteurs du
château de versailles elles sont en
train de réaliser des panneaux
décoratifs
d'inspiration 18e qui sont qu'on appelle
des grotesques et voilà qui
leur demande d'avoir une forme de
dextérité dans le maniement du du
pinceau non dont le geste sont des
ornements qui
ont pour caractéristique justement que
d'être adapté au pinceau c'est le sait
le pinceau qui fait la forme
au test du faux marbres ici au château
de versailles le trompe l'oeil a toute
sa place son est même presque les sens
certes on a du vrai marbre on a de la
vraie pierre on a des boiseries
magnifique mais on a aussi des
trompe-l'oeil ce soit du bois que ce
soit de bas reliefs
ce soit du faux marbre il ya des
trompe-l'oeil qui sont uniquement
décoratif et d'autres qui couche jusqu'à
être vraiment illusionniste dans toute
la peinture classique il ya une notion
de trompe l'oeil qui existe
là il ya des cages d'escaliers
entièrement une fausse molière beaucoup
de faux marbres ici
un peu partout mais les eaux aux vraies
marques d'ailleurs on a parfois du mal à
distinguer j'aime bien tout les
imitations fait de faux donné
l'impression de en fait et c'est quelque
chose qui est très intéressant et très
très bluffant en fait si
l'école d'art mural de versailles avait
toute sa raison d'être ici au château
une façon aussi de faire connaître
l'établissement installé dans le
quartier notre dame une structure qui
accueille peu d'élèves une vingtaine
seulement par session et à l'issue de la
formation d'une année 100 personnes sont
valeur sûre de trouver
cette année en france est d'abord de
quoi je pense c'est renommée dans le
monde qui pour la raison en est quand
même à versailles pour essayer de parler
des 7 cette activité il ya une vraie
demande pour cette activité même par des
entreprises internationales alors les
élèves ont travaillé pour des
entreprises qui se trouve à paris comme
également ils sont maintenant demander
de d'autres pays comme en russie comment
en chine est maintenant à dubai dont le
trompe l'oeil à savoir faire dont on
retrouve des traces des mots xvème
siècle un art qui se développe en france
au xviiie siècle un vrai style de
précision et du détail
coup de projecteur maintenant sur les
sorties cinéma de la semaine
je vous propose maintenant de découvre
de retrouver la chronique cinéphiles et
nous débutons par les avis des
spectateurs au mic au micro de mathilde
de capvern je les trouvais un peu pâteux
en soit l'adaptation est plutôt bonne
pour avoir lu le roman voit les décors
et les costumes la reconstitution est
vraiment impeccable et n'en soit le
scénario fonctionne bien et pour ceux
qui aiment tout ce qui tourne autour la
seconde guerre mondiale sont satisfaits
ah oui un très très bon moment vraiment
exceptionnel comme film vraiment
exceptionnel c'est vraiment un film a
recommandé
les actes et les acteurs formidables
formidable emma de caunes on la voit pas
assez et très très bonne actrice ils
sont tous très très bien
traitée très émouvant
ah oui je vais recommander autour de moi
oui très intéressant et puis la
condition de vie de ces temps là c'était
triste pour les gens qui devaient subir
les patrons c'est surtout moi sur la
condition de la femme sama ça me fait
rappeler un peu les romans de jane
austen soit les femmes étaient obligés
de se marier soit elle est obligée de
subir nous poursuivons avec le coup de
coeur cinéma de cette semaine direction
le grenier à sel de trappes avec gail
pinault bonjour cette semaine au cinéma
le grenier à sel nous participons au
festival cinéma du réel qui est
organisée par la bibliothèque du centre
pompidou à paris c'est un festival
international de films documentaires
nous recevons
le réalisateur du film ancré qui
s'appelle à rachid djaïdani son film est
présenté dans le
festival dans le cadre de la sélection
française et rachid djaïdani il a
réalisé en 2012 le film le film rengaine
et il revient là avec un portrait d'un
artiste un peintre contemporain qui
s'appelle yaz et on le voit pendant le
film on le voit donc c'est un
documentaire c'est la vraie vie on voit
réellement se faire se fâcher avec sa
galerie à paris se retrouvait son
galerie donc plus aucun moyen de montrer
ses oeuvres les vendent ou de vivre et
il va galérer il va on va le voir en
période de création donc c'est assez
c'est assez joli à voir c'était sympa à
6 et assister à cela cette création et
ensuite on va le voir aussi rechercher
une galerie et donc c'est pas une
surprise c'est pas un secret je peux le
dire quasiment la fin du film il va
finir dans une galerie à new york qui
n'était pas encore ouvert qui va falloir
qu'ils limitent le projet de toutes
pièces et est donc c'est une énorme
aventure qui on va suivre pendant une
heure et quart avec
avec le réalisateur et peut-être y
associe qui sera peut-être là ce sera
donc vendredi 3 avril à 20h45
l'entrée est libre sur réservation vous
retrouver tout ça sent le site internet
www.cineagde.com à bientôt merci
après le cinéma on passe maintenant
résultats sportifs au rendez vous
sportifs du week-end
le week-end sera sportive sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
alexandre vialle vous propose ce samedi
et ce dimanche à 9h30 un circuit
training sur la communauté
d'agglomération alors bonjour alors
est-ce qu'on peut le présenter un petit
peu votre concept votre projet en fait
moi je veux proposer du circuit training
en fait surtout le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines donc du circuit
training en fait c'est des ateliers
sportifs qui mélange la musculation et
du cardio et je compte le faire en fait
sur tout le territoire de saint quentin
c'est à dire chaque semaine évoluer à
divers endroits étant donné qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un territoire riche en
milieux naturels donc je vais pouvoir en
même temps proposer des séances de sport
mais aussi faire découvrir pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas certains endroits
de la ville noël et justement pourquoi
avoir choisi à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du coup pour votre circuit training mais
en fait moi je suis et l'on côtoie
depuis depuis quasiment vingt ans et
j'ai voulu moi je fais ma pratique donc
sur le secteur de 55 et j'aime bien
régulièrement changés ce qui fait que
j'ai envie de faire découvrir ce panel
de commandes de
ce ce panel de choix qu'on peut avoir
non pas spécialement que pour la
pratique sportive mais aussi ne serait
ce que pour aller se balader ou des
endroits ne serait-ce que de se poser
que les enfants ou quoi que ce soit donc
il ya tellement de choix varié sur le
secteur la lune nouvelle que j'ai envie
de faire partager et à ce que vos
séances sont vraiment tous publics ou
est-ce qu'il faut avoir quand même un
certain niveau pour nourrir cette
réunion dans le gros avantage du circuit
training en fait c'est qu'il est
adaptable en fait à tous les niveaux
donc c'est pour ça que je les prêts je
le précise bien comme quoi celui qui a
envie de faire du sport qui part d'une
base 0 ou alors ceux qui veulent se
remettre au sport celui qui a déjà une
base ils peuvent venir étant donné que
tout est lié à l'intensité que vous
allez mettre de vous sur sur les
programmes dont tout le monde est
bienvenu et je m'adapte en fait à chaque
fois sur un débutant peut parfaitement
intégré au groupe ah oui tout à fait
tout à fait oui oui c'est le but c'est
d'être à plusieurs justement parce qu'on
joue sur la motivation est sûre l'esprit
convivialité et à ce que justement aussi
certains peut-être sportif qui cherche
la performance peuvent également faire
partie de ce training oui tout à fait
parce que les exercices en fait que je
propose est ce que ça permet de justin
de ses muscles et de vraiment être plus
endurant le circuit training le gros
avantage c'est que vous combinez en fait
donc la muscu et le cardio et dans un
temps réduit ce qui fait qu'on joue
beaucoup sur les temps de récupération
les choses comme ça donc quelqu'un qui
est un sportif déjà un peu aguerris peut
très bien venir comment dire pratiques
et parce que de toute façon en terme de
difficulté j'adapte à chaque fois la
difficulté par rapport à la personne
dont il ya toujours il ya toujours moyen
de s'adapter par l'udc et du coup ça se
fait principalement donc en extérieur
enfin mis totalement l'extérieur est
long du jeu est ce que vous craignez pas
justement que ça décourage un petit peu
les gens que ça se fasse en extérieur si
fait s'il pleut s'il fait mauvais non
non alors que ça les décourage non parce
que de toute façon en extérieur on est
mieux enfin je parle d'un point de vue
personnel on est beaucoup mieux beaucoup
plus à l'aise en extérieur et puis on
s'oxygène davantage donc il ya une
notion de plaisir en extérieur comme
autrefois lorsqu'on est confiné un peu
dans une salle et par rapport à tout ce
qui est lié à la météo mise à part le
fait qu'on me tombe sur une météo qui
sont vraiment impraticable dans quelques
gouttes de pluie ou un peu devant nous
un peu de le froid ne repousse pas le
fait de faire du sport vous pouvez le
voir autour de vous même les gens qui
courent en plein hiver au caucus comme
vous en croisez beaucoup donc non non
c'est pas une crainte loin de moi est ce
que vous attendez beaucoup de monde du
coup pour ces pour pour ses ateliers en
fait j'ai moi j'ai limité les places
mais créneau je les propose à 12
personnes maximum parce que je veux
garder ce côté humain en fait de groupes
et non pas le faire
le l'ouvrir trop de personnes en fait
ils ont créé dans le dans
l'environnement naturel une pollution
une pollution le fait de trop dans un
même endroit en quoi que ce soit ne
serait ce que pour le respect de
l'environnement le fait de faire du
sport on peut très vite détérioré que ce
soit donc c'est pour ça que je les
réduit à douze personnes et je le
propose ça donc le samedi matin ainsi
que le dimanche matin
donc si on veut s'inscrire à vos cours
du coup on fait comment alors pour
s'inscrire aussi simple soit vous me
contacter via mon site internet donc
www.alexisminerals.com chez vous avez
aussi mon facebook donc et en lien sur
le site internet ou alors directement
sur mon portable au 06 27 69 61 63 et je
peux vous annoncer que la première
séance donc aura lieu donc demain et
après demain donc ça dimanche à 9h30 à
9h30 on va combler ou s'il reste des
places l'aspect de place et ça sera au
bassin de la courance de maurepas merci
beaucoup alexander j allais être passé
sur ce plateau jours mais bon courage du
coup bonne continuation d'un coup pour
vos ateliers bien voilà et pour
continuer cette émission de rendez vous
sports à ne pas manquer ce week end en
football américain les templiers
d'elancourt joue un match très important
ce week-end mal embarqué dans ce
championnat élite les élans courtois
reçoivent les molosses d'asnières ce
samedi à 20h pour le compte de la 5e
journée du championnat élite victoire
impérative pour les yvelinois les
templiers ont remporté seulement un
match depuis le début de la saison si
vous voulez les soutenir la rencontre
est programmée à 20h au complexe sportif
europe
il y aura également de la course à pied
ce dimanche avec la 20e édition de la
nuit en course le départ du 10 km sera
donné à 9h30 du gymnase des droits de
l'homme à guyancourt le parcours sera
une nouvelle fois technique avec une
bouée grande boucle en nature sur un
terrain vallonné il y aura également un
tronçon sur route aux alentours du
gymnase au total plus de 500 personnes
devraient participer à la compétition
c'est la fin de 7,8 week end je vous
retrouve mardi prochain pour un numéro
du 7-8 sport nous parlerons des
templiers d'elancourt en football
américain et de l'équipe de basket de
trappes excellent week-end sur tv fils à